[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction de tv
fil 78 le point sur l'actualité locale
voici les principaux titres en images
retour sur le débat houleux de
l'entre-deux tours qui se déroulait hier
soir vos avis les réactions des
représentants locaux du mouvement en
marche et du front national à suivre à
saint quentin en yvelines se dérouler
aujourd'hui la nouvelle édition du
challenge de robotique sky robe neuf
communes représentées plus de 600 élèves
issus de 37 classes un pas de plus vers
l'école du futur
et puis nos conseils avant de remplir
vos déclarations de revenus vous avez
jusqu'au 6 juin nous verrons comment
être accompagnées dans les yvelines pour
débuter nous revenons sur ce ait des
débats d'hier entre les deux finalistes
à l'élection présidentielle débat sous
tension aux tons a particulièrement
agressif une brutalité rarement vus et
qui de l'avis des analystes
elle devrait être plutôt défavorable à
marine le pen 16 millions et demi de
français étaient devant leur télé et
notamment les représentants
départementaux des mouvements en marche
et du front national
écouter à ses réactions moi je pense que
c'est un débat qui était nécessaire
il a permis vraiment d'éclairer sur les
sur les postures des candidats des deux
des deux finalistes
on le voit dès ce matin sur mansion le
terrain est elle beaucoup de gens qui
s'était mis en retrait peut-être
abstentionnistes et être sur un vote
blanc je pense qu'ils ont vraiment pris
conscience de ce que représente et
marine le pen et du danger qu'elles
représentent est avec un programme écrit
cette invention de péter même si c'était
peut-être pas les noms ainsi emmanuel
macron n'était pas le leur candidat
préféré être à voter pour emmanuel
macron qui remet toi je pense que
beaucoup d'abstentionnistes vont changer
de côté je précise que nous n'avons pas
réussi à contacter aujourd'hui à joindre
par téléphone le responsable
départemental du front national écoutez
néanmoins ces quelques réactions de
saint quentinois des propos recueillis
par stéphane servant et patrick jacques
de dixmude ce matin dans les rues de
saint quentin en yvelines
libérez agressif il y avait jamais rien
n'y avait pas aucune consistance
voilà donc à partir de là dur dur pour
faire un choix
bah oui j'étais pas vraiment macron là
j'ai trouvé qu'il était beaucoup plus
clair sur ses idées
oui s'expliquer beaucoup mieux il avait
l'air très posé il avait aucun dossier
avec lui enfin j'ai trouvé comment il
avait un match de boxe bat c'était
vraiment catastrophique et c'était
vraiment à la pâte projet du tout marine
le pen et je pense que les pas du tout à
la hauteur
il s'interrompt paix sans cesse et le
journaliste maîtrisé par la situation
marine le pen est l'attaqué telle une
furie lui je crois qu'ils accueillent
garder son calme
nous continuons à parler de cette
présidentielle avec un point souvent
évoqué pendant la campagne l'avenir du
cic le crédit impôt pour la
compétitivité et l'emploi dans les
yvelines 610 millions d'euros ont été
attribués à des entreprises depuis la
mise en place du dispositif en 2013 ce
qui va changer en fonction du résultat
du scrutin de dimanche avec nicolas
landry vous le connaissez comme
président du medef des yvelines bertrand
de craie aussi directeur d'un
supermarché à fontenay le fleury son
entreprise bénéficie du crédit impôt
pour la compétitivité et l'emploi en
2016 il a économisé environ 70000 euros
nous avons investi essentiellement sur
le service je l'avais cette bouche
boucherie peu favori forage coupe on a
fait les travaux cet été
embauche pas seul en septembre le cic s
imputé sur l'impôt sur les sociétés à
hauteur de 7 % des salaires inférieurs à
2,5 fois le smic
dans les yvelines en 2014 près de 16000
employeurs ont bénéficié du dispositif
plus de 13000 en 2015 pour un montant
qui augmente de plus de 100 millions
d'euros en deux ans une mesure critiquée
par la cgt le cicr n'atteint pas les
objectifs que le gouvernement lui avait
fixés
que ce soit en termes de création
d'emplois d'innovation
les deux candidats à l'élection
présidentielle souhaite transformer le
cic eux en allègements de charges pour
la candidate du front national la
priorité est donnée aux tpe pme sous
condition de maintien de l'emploi
emmanuel macron veut généraliser
la baisse des charges pour favoriser
l'embauché pour moi je ne sais pas
combien comment voilà aujourd'hui je ne
peux pas me prononcer est ce que ce sera
plus - que le cce
je sais pas nous on pense déjà que tous
les dispositifs qui baissent les
cotisations sociales des employeurs
c'est prouvé que c'est inefficace
concernant l'impôt sur les sociétés le
candidat en marche souhaite réduire le
taux de 33 3 % à 25 % à la fin de son
quinquennat
marine le pen propose un taux
intermédiaire à 24 % pour les pme c'est
un rituel chaque année qui n'est pas
toujours plaisant mais néanmoins c'est
obligatoire la déclaration des revenus
cela concerne plus de 750 mille
contribuables dans le département des
yvelines alors quelle est la date limite
pour déclarer quels sont les conseils
les choses à savoir nous faisons le
point avec nicolas qui est le vide
bonsoir bonsoir et pour les yvelinois
wilfried deux dates à retenir pour
déclarer leurs revenus
celles qui concernent la limite pour
remplir son devoir fiscal si vous êtes
toujours avec la méthode papier vous
avez jusqu'au mercredi 17 mai minuit
pour envoyer votre déclaration le cachet
de la poste évidemment en fait foi
si en revanche vous êtes avec internet
vous avez un peu plus de temps jusqu'au
mardi 6 juin minuit et respectez bien
ces délais sinon vous encourez une
majoration de 10 à 40% sur vos impôts
qui ne vous seront envoyées durant l'été
l'an passé dans les yvelines un peu plus
de quatre cent quarante mille personnes
avaient choisi internet pour faire leur
déclaration soit 59% du total
et attention on le précise la
déclaration en ligne est désormais
obligatoire si vous disposez d'une
connexion internet jusque là ça devrait
concerner beaucoup de monde et surtout
si votre revenu fiscal de référence en
2015 est supérieur à 28 milles euros
c'est un peu complexe mais il faut le
dire en gros qu'il est préférable de
déclarer ses revenus via internet
tailleur dont deux ans tout le monde
sera obligé de le faire via internet
ça peut paraître simple comme ça de
faire sa déclaration qui est déjà prêt
remplies via internet mais lorsqu'il ya
des changements de situation c'est un
peu plus compliqué oui ça peut rester
casse tête surtout si vous
on change de situation si sa situation
financière évolue con ce qu'on divorce
ou plus heureux qu'on se marie plusieurs
solutions existent
alors consultez le site internet du
gouvernement www.impots.gouv.fr le site
a été modernisé cette année et guides
par exemple les plus jeunes dans leurs
premières déclarations ou sinon appelé à
l'eau impôts on voit le numéro à l'écran
c'est un numéro vert gratuit mis en
place par l'ordre des experts comptables
avec une assistance téléphonique qui
fonctionnera du 15 au 23 mai prochains
de 9h à 19h et bonne nouvelle en
ile-de-france on pourra même prendre des
rendez vous en direct vis-à-vis on sera
obligé de se déclarer au niger en recul
même si on disait tout à l'heure c'est
pas forcément plaisant merci nicolas
autre sujet et puis cette question
qu'est ce que la citoyenneté 130 morts
passe bien on tue un aperçu en tout cas
aujourd'hui
ce sont des élèves de l'école défricher
du collège pergaud de la commune qui ont
participé un parcours citoyens et
institutions initiée par leurs
professeurs face à eux des pompiers des
policiers
mon corps des gendarmes le reportage est
signée mélanie poker met toi bien relevé
et la vraie comprimé
après cet atelier le massage cardiaque
n'aura plus de secret pour eux c'est
mort passe bien participent à la journée
citoyenneté organisée par leurs
professeurs
vachalé pas pour les massages cardiaques
n'avaient pas pesant peu fallait faire
poussée d'air comme ça j'avais pas j'ai
appris plein de choses
il ya plusieurs choses que j'avais déjà
fait mais après après le le le truc pour
réanimer une personne j'avais jamais
fait protection civile policiers ou
encore sécurité routière étaient
mobilisés des ateliers étaient proposés
pour parfois défaire elle les idées
reçues nous sommes un atelier de
parcours vélo donc on apprend aux élèves
principalement à s'arrêter au stop
comprendre qu'on s'arrête trois secondes
à un stop le ciel et le passage là et vu
qu'à un sens giratoire à différence
entre un giratoire et un rond-point bons
jeux de bonnes connaissances ensemble et
puis il ya l'effet mimétisme avec l'épée
avec les parents les parents dans la
voiture
les enfants sont des éponges et il
récupère bien sûr tout ce que les
parents font bien ou mal
cent trente élèves ont été sensibilisés
le temps de cette journée pour que la
théorie apprise à l'école passe à la
pratique et dans l'actualité du jour
également la salle de spectacle du
prisme à elancourt transformé en
laboratoire d'expériences robotique le
deuxième challenge kodak codage pardon
et robotique baptisé skyrock a mobilisé
une vingtaine d'établissements de saint
quentin en yvelines
le reportage de camille lambert il a des
allures de vaisseau spatial et fait la
fierté de ses créateurs signaux a été
entièrement programmée par ses élèves de
ce2 de l'école le berceau avec les hardy
au programme
le robot et après on appuie sur le
bouton du milieu et
d'après le programme commence un langage
qui n'a presque plus de secrets pour eux
une trentaine de classes de saint
quentin en yvelines a participé au 2e
challenge sky robe
depuis septembre ils ont travaillé avec
leurs professeurs pour arriver à ce
résultat
ils apprennent à prendre avec un robot à
connaître le vocabulaire se sert le
robot et puis aussi le vocabulaire
utilisé par le robot pour avancer et
obéir sur l'allemande aux ordres qui
vont leur donner
donc ça apprend dans toute chose en
termes pédagogiques mais ça apprend
aussi l'esprit d'équipé parce qu'ils
sont pas tout seul à le faire
j'ai bien mécanique c'est ce qui fait
fonctionner à leurs haut-parleurs ou
cette façon sur le robot seller mont
blanc après délibération du jury dark
team york repart avec le prix coup de
coeur mais chaque équipe a été
récompensé pour son investissement
cette année plus de 600 élèves sont
devenus apprentis ingénieurs et pendant
que certains se familiarise avec la
profession d'ingénieur d'autres
s'entraînent au rugby avec des athlètes
de haut niveau l'école de rugby de
montfort l'amaury a accueilli des
joueurs professionnels du top 14 du
racing 92 pour participer à
l'entraînement un des plus jeunes sujets
signé maxime le maine pour le conseil
départemental des yvelines
un mercredi pas comme les autres pour
ces jeunes de l'école de rugby de
montfort l'amaury qui ont reçu la visite
de xavier chauveau et sautent à la face
aux deux joueurs du racing 92
ils sont allés voir un peu chaque
entraînement comme sont les plus petits
jusqu'aux grands et il s'amusait il
rigolé et l'ice en séance d'autographes
situées en zone rurale
l'école de rugby de montfort l'amaury
existe depuis seulement neuf ans elle
regroupe des enfants venus d'une
quarantaine de communes et dispose déjà
de titres départementaux et régionaux
c'est une opération cap a également
exceptionnel porno
qui fait le bonheur d'abord des enfants
parce que c'est d'abord pour eux que
que l'on fait tous avec l'école existe
et puis aussi c'est une source de
motivation pour pour tous les bénévoles
qui permettent de faire vivre l'école
cette rencontre intervenait dans le
cadre d'un partenariat entre le
département et le racing 92
le principe permettre à des jeunes
rugbymen yvelinois de partager des
moments privilégiés avec des
professionnels du ballon ovale ont ça me
fait toujours plaisir de revenir voir un
petit peu comment ça se passe sur les
écoles de rugby voilà c'est là qu'on a
commencé donc on se régale avoir à voir
les petits jeux et à partager ces
moments là avec le message qu'on veut
leur faire passer c'est prenez du
plaisir
le rugby est un sport pour tous peu
importe qui vous êtes à n'importe quel
âge que vous soyez un garçon ou une
fille si vous vous amusez en jouant au
rugby alors continuer chaque année le
département investit 50 mille euros dans
ce partenariat prochaine opération fin
août à l'occasion d'un stage des cas des
yvelinois auront le privilège de visiter
le centre d'entraînement du racing 92 et
pour terminer ce journal a rendez vous à
noter dans vos agendas samedi 6 mai à
partir de 15h vincent vinel sera en
concert au magasin cultura des
clayes-sous-bois son nom ne vous est pas
encore familier mais peut-être avez-vous
entendu parler de sa prestation dans
l'émission the voice
vincent vinel participent à cette
édition il réalise un bon parcours elle
sa reprise d' eminem avait séduit les
coachs et notamment mis car pour
découvrir son univers rendez vous donc
ce week end aux clayes-sous-bois samedi
à partir de 15h pour ce concert merci
d'avoir suivi ce journal les programmes
se poursuivent sur tv fil 78 journal a
retrouvé en replay sur notre site
internet et via notre application mobile
demain aux horaires habituels
l'hebdo avec nikola kirillovitch pour
l'essentiel de la semaine je vous
retrouve lundi à partir de 18 heures
pour une édition spéciale second tour de
la présidentielle et l'analyse des
résultats dans les yvelines très belle
soirée
[Musique]